I just wanted to sort of clear the air
for everyone and and be and I wanted it
coming from my mouth I wanted people to
hear everything from me and and then
this is it Megan Fox and Brian Austin
Green are splitting up after ten years
of marriage
Brian made an official announcement
Monday on his podcast neither one of us
did anything to each other she's always
been honest with me I've always been
honest with her we've had an amazing an
amazing relationship and
and I will I will always love her and I
know she'll always love me and I know I
know that like as far as a family like
what we built is really is really cool
it's really special Fox had previously
filed for divorce from green in 2015 but
they reconciled the following year and
she became pregnant with their third
child it sucks when when life changes
and something that you're used to that
you've been doing for 15 years you you
try and you try and not get rid of but
you you you change I really don't want I
really don't want Megan and I to be at
odds because at the end of it all like
we'd been married and we've done all
that but she's she's been my my best
friend for 15 years
brian revealed they began to grow apart
at the end of last year after Megan had
been away on a film shoot for five weeks
there's the sense of of loss of you know
how do i how do i go on with this big
part of my life that that i've always
known and and loved and and and chaired
changing like how does you know how does
where does that landscape look like like
what does that life look like Megan and
Brian also shared three children Noah
Bodhi and journey the couple began
dating in 2004 after meeting on the set
of her sitcom hope and faith they tied
the knot in 2010 we talked about the
fact that you know separation we can't
we can't pretend that it doesn't that it
won't affect the kids because it will
but the control we have is how it
affects the kids Brian also commented on
recent photos of Megan with Machine Gun
Kelly the rapper whose real name is
Colson Baker met Megan while filming
their upcoming movie Megan has continued
working and
doing that and you know she met she met
this this guy Colson on onset on this
film she's working on Megan and I have
talked about him and and they're their
friends at this point I trust her
judgment she's always had really good
judgment and and I don't I don't want
people to think that her or he are
villains or or I was I was a victim in
any way
last year Megan told ET how her children
with Brian gave her a new perspective
after a rocky relationship with
Hollywood and I think it took getting
pregnant that was the first real
breakthrough where I had where I might
my consciousness shifted in my mind
opened up and I was able to see from our
bird's eye view and breathe and take it
in and and have a different perspective
and then another kid and then another
kid in with every kid I feel like that's
always been the doorway into a better
version of myself because they're you
know they're the mirrors that show you
your shadow you have to look at it and
go this is Who I am and I have to
acknowledge that and I have to grow and
I have to change it
[Music]